eu valorem team vodafone giants has been
handed a
one-map loss by riot for exploiting a
bug
in their recent valor and champions tour
match now this isn't the first time the
pros have been accused of exploiting a
bug
and just like last time riot has now
finally
punished them for the victims of this
bug exploit though
their loss still stands and they feel
that riot
and the tournament organizers could have
done a lot more
[Music]
bugs cheaters scammers fakes and frauds
we cover all that good stuff here on
don't at me you did manage to catch this
particular video
but to make sure you never miss one in
the future make sure you are subscribed
to the score
esports it's a decision you will not
regret
so on july 6 riot released a statement
addressing the exploitation
of a bug in a recent vct challenges
match by vodafone
giants they said after their match
against team breath in the vct
challengers eu stage 3 week 1 qualifier
tournament officials were made aware of
the exploit and after further
investigation
confirmed its use intentional use of an
in-game bug to seek an advantage is
explicitly prohibited all teams are
expected to uphold the standards of
competitive integrity outlined in the
valorum global competition
policy the bug in question revolves
around cipher's spy cam it allows cypher
to see
a sight on breeze without the attackers
being able to see the cam unless they
push
further into the site according to riot
vodafone giants
exploited this bug in their 2-1 victory
over team
breath in the vct stage 3 eu
open qualifiers members of team breath
took to twitter and read it almost
immediately after the game to call out
the exploit one of the players
dawn made a reddit post where he
provided footage to demonstrate the
actual
book you can clearly see that from this
spot a player can't see the cam
on top of the awning but when we switch
to the cams view
the player is clearly visible this
obviously provides a huge advantage to a
cipher that's defending a site
they can see who's coming without the
cam being seen itself
dawn then shared some footage which
allegedly shows giants
using this bug to their advantage in the
vct game
in this reddit post dawn said that
giants exploited the bug
a minimum of six times out of 12 rounds
on the map
not only could they see any attackers
coming into a site from that angle
they could also know if they weren't
attacking a site that knowledge
is incredibly valuable i spoke to dawn
to find out more
he told me that the bug exploiting meant
that they weren't able to even follow
their game plan
so our game plan was totally useless
because of this
so they were aware of everything so in
game
i was like why is nothing working
why do they know every time that we're
we're not
on a or anything the game passes and
on the last map we're just you know
we're a bit unfocused because the
the best shot we had was on breeze
because the map was new
although dawn was confused and a little
bit skeptical of the result it wasn't
until
after the game that he realized they've
been victims of a bug exploit
bds logan a player from another team
reached out to dawn after the game and
told him that he knew about this bug and
suspected
that vodafone giants had been using it
it was then that dawn reached out to
jorg jacob
a manager for the vct tournament
organizers
freaks for you gaming jakob said they
were investigating but that any use of
the camera will
not change the result of the match when
dawn pushed him for more
jakob said quote because of the
procedure of how
bug using is handled in the first step a
team gets informed that they are using a
bug
and get warmed without any impact to
their result
until now the camera is allowed since
it's not listed as a bug
at all like i said we are in the
investigation
and until we finish it with riot this is
not forbidden
for dawn though this answer just wasn't
good enough
when the admin told me this i instantly
write but
bro the the map was just released so
obviously
this cam is new to everyone you know so
in my opinion they they sh even if they
had they don't have
that much power uh they should at least
pause the match and talk to red you know
and not give the the win to giant anyway
dawn has a point here up until now
riot's policy has been to investigate
and deal with the issue
after the game now this isn't the first
time that something like this has
happened either back in november 2020
guild esports were handed a forfeit loss
from riot for using an exploit
in their qualifiers match versus g2
guild were accused of using an illegal
boost
with a sage wall on a sense b site riot
released a statement the following day
in which they explained that guild were
being handed a forfeit loss but would be
eligible to play in qualifiers the next
week
it was a pretty contentious decision at
the time in other games like cs go plays
like the infamous olaf boost have gone
down in history
more as iconic moments despite the
similarity between the cases
what's more this is almost certainly not
the last time we're going to be dealing
with bugs like these
prior to or even during major valorem
tournaments
so far in valorem we've seen
undetectable cipher cams hidden behind
boxes and even in that frog's mouth on
split
not to mention omen teleporting out of
the map
and cypher breaking sage walls with his
camera and don't even get me started on
how
buggy skye's cabbages are the point is
the game has a lot of complicated [ __ ]
going on and has the potential
to keep happening while they're tuning
the game and making new maps
so although we do have an example of
riot dealing with valor and bugs fairly
quickly
that wasn't the case with this latest
cipher cam bug
it took riot eight days to investigate
and publish their report
they said team vodafone giants will
receive a one map
loss applied to their next official
valorem champions tour match
due to violating rules regarding
competitive integrity
and use of in-game exploits the rule in
question was rule
7.2.6 exploiting which riot also
included in their statement
intentionally using any in-game bug to
seek an advantage
is exploiting and is prohibited
exploiting includes acts such as making
use of any game function
that in the tournament operator's soul
judgment is not functioning as intended
and violates the design purpose of varan
team members may confidentially check
with the referee
at the beginning of a competition to
determine if a specific act would be
considered exploiting
riot reserves the right to make an ex
post facto determination of whether an
exploit has occurred
now according to dawn players had
notified riot about this bug on their
new map
but they clearly didn't act on it before
this game so
let's talk about the punishment now in
dawn's reddit post he was calling for a
rematch or even disqualification for
vodafone giants
when i spoke to him on the day of riot's
ruling he elaborated on those thoughts
i think really this this
punishment isn't really a punishment
it's everyone is losing
giant is losing because they they bench
two players
and they will have two new players that
have
nothing related to this that will get
punished because of this and our team
is not like we don't have any benefits
for this
in my opinion it's just they just uh
acted uh to say like hey guys hello we
reacted
it's either you act the very day when it
happened
or either you don't do anything at all
and this really gets to the heart of
dawn's frustration here that the
tournament organizers
didn't take any action during the game
and that's fair enough if we talk about
one match but
what about the game at large here if
riot does identify a problem with an
agent
it's a difficult decision about whether
or not to disable the agent or a
specific part of their kit
such as cipher's cameras and there will
be new maps in the future
like breeze where bugs don't get fully
exposed until the pros play on them
this problem isn't entirely avoidable
it's tricky
so what's the solution here well for
dawn it isn't that riot has to make the
right decision
immediately with a hundred percent
accuracy
it's that they need to make a decision
any decision
a lot quicker we just need the admins to
take actions the very day we need the
admins to
talk to us at least at least respond
they just have to
respond quicker like they have to take
position if even if if it's a bad
decision you have to take one at least
for dawn and team breath
riot's ruling won't bring back their
loss in the qualifiers which does still
stand
so will we see more of this in the
future or will riot
act on bug abusers quicker perhaps even
reversing game results
as valorum continues to grow
there was a pop song in like in the
early 2000s
in the uk and then like people just
revived that and then when
gareth southgate became a new england
manager people just well england fancy
winger fans do best and just
made a song
[Music]
looking back to where we first met
i cannot escape but i cannot forget
so sasuke you're the one you still turn
me on
football's coming over